hello and some breaking news this
afternoon a new potential covert 19
vaccine
has been announced the jab is said to be
94.5
effective and is being produced in the
united states by the biotech firm
moderna well let's go straight disguise
ashna huranag who is in the newsroom for
us
uh this is a good news on top of last
week's good news what do we know about
this latest vaccine it's good news for
sure jane in the form that this
is much more effective effective 94.5
effective impact which is much more than
the pfizer and biontech one that we
heard about last week where theirs we
now know is more than 90 percent
effective early results
are showing for there but crucially for
this moderna vaccine
this is not one that's been bought by
the uk yet we've got six others in our
stockpile including the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
and also this fisa one as well but
moderna who are based in the
u.s have got vaccines really in supply
mostly for the united states the united
states have already purchased a hundred
million doses of this particular one
what's interesting about it is that it
can be stored at a much lower
temperature
a much higher temperature i should say
minus 20 is all it needs to be
stored in to be distributed in which
makes it much more easier to farm out
and roll out
when it comes to that vaccine being
administered the other good thing about
it
is it can be kept at that freezer
temperature for 30 days and that's a
drastic difference to the fisa one
that pfizer vaccine has to be kept at
minus 80 degrees and you can only only
imagine how difficult that is
to transport around the country in
freezes that keep
those vaccinations at minus 80 degrees
so some key differences here moderna's
vaccine appears to be
much more effective 94.5 but it's also
easier than what it appears to be to
distribute and crucially the uk hasn't
got access to any of them yet
but there are there is some good news
for the uk in the form of another
pharmaceutical giant which has produced
another vaccine which is entering human
trials
uh jansen or johnson johnson a german
company are
currently putting their vaccine forward
for human trials
much in the same way that we've seen now
the oxford and astrazeneca
vaccine going through similar human
trials what this company are hoping to
do
johnson is recruit about 6 000
volunteers by march next year
and their trial will last 12 months
earlier we spoke to the chief
scientific officer for johnson and
here's what he had to say on how
promising
this other vaccine could be we start
manufacturing as we speak of course
we have to get the approval from the
government uh from the regulators in the
world
to start distributing but we have uh
manufactured already a first batches of
this vaccine
in our plants we have probably five to
ten thousand people
worldwide on this at the moment working
day in day out
weekend in week out and it's not just us
it's also
the clinical investigators for example
recruiting
people over the weekend the regulators
who give
responses on their documents within days
sometimes
even hours so everyone who is working in
this space scientifically at the moment
has an extreme commitment we know we can
do it
it's a matter now of of speed and time
to get there
in order to be able to give give relief
to people from this pandemic and that we
can put it behind us very quickly
immunization experts say it's really
important that we have a number of
vaccines to play with and we do
trial and test as many as possible
that's because we don't know if one
particular vaccine is able to
work for people of all ages for all all
sorts of the population but also we
don't know whether one vaccine
pharmaceutical supplier is able to
supply enough a large
enough supply to to take on the whole of
the uk
crucially for this johnson one if
approved if proven to be effective we
could have 30 million doses
here in the uk being distributed by
mid-2021